MING TAN: Well, good
morning, my friends.
My name is Ming, and I'm the
jolly good fellow of Google.
During my long tenure in Google,
I have hosted many luminaries,
and they all have one thing
in common, they're all adults.
And adults are boring.
But not today, my friends.
Today my very special
guest, Vivienne Harr,
is only 10 years old.
At the age of ten
she has already
been working to save
the world for two years.
And she's already given
more money to charity
than most adults have
given in their lifetimes.
And she's already an inspiration
for millions of people,
including myself.
When I grow up, I want to
be a lot more like her.
When Vivienne was
eight years old,
she learned that there was
child slavery in the world.
And she was deeply
troubled by it.
So she decided to make a
lemonade stand every day
until she raised $100,000
to end child slavery.
And she succeeded
in raising $100,000.
So two years later,
she and her family,
her lovely family
is here, has started
a Make a Stand-- Make
a Stand Lemon-Aid.
See, I have to read this.
I told you, adults are boring.
A social impact brand that
supports Vivienne's vision
of a world where all 18
million enslaved children
are free and safe.
Vivienne has won the George H.
W. Bush Point of Light award.
She was recognized as one
of 50 most influential
philanthropists in America.
She once rang the
opening bell for NASDAQ.
She is the youngest person
ever featured at TED.
And she's just an
amazing human being.
And with that my friends,
please give a warm
welcome to Vivienne Harr.
[APPLAUSE]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-So serendipitous the
way all of this occurred.
Alex and I were up on a
date weekend in Sonoma.
And we were drinking
wine and eating cheese
and blissfully unaware of a
lot of the evils in the world.
And we stroll into
this gallery, and there
was one photo in particular
of these two boys,
roughly my daughter's age, who
have these giant rocks strapped
to their heads.
Alex starts weeping
uncontrollably, shaking,
thinking that that
could be our kids.
-They go out and they work.
And they get really sad.
And they cry.
And whenever they cry
and try and run away,
bad things happen.
And it's like
living a nightmare.
-She said I want to
free 500 of these kids.
And it was this
gigantic, audacious goal.
And we're thinking, OK,
wow, talk to us about this.
-And we said, well,
that's $150,000.
How are we going to do that?
And she said, I could
tell my lemonade.
-When Vivian first started
her lemonade stand,
she was charging $2 a cup.
And we're getting nowhere.
She wants to raise $150,000,
and we're $81 into it.
I said, Vivienne, we're going to
have to do something different,
because we're not
making any headway.
-We made it free and pay
what's in your heart.
And it just started
going up and up and up.
-And she wants you to
make a stand with her
for a very special cause.
-A little girl
from the North Bay
is fighting against
child slavery.
-She's making her
mark on the world.
-I am Vivienne.
I am nine.
I have been making a stand
for 322 days in a row.
-People fall into slavery,
not because they're willing
and not because
they're stupid, it's
because they've been lied to.
-It exists everywhere.
Every country is
afflicted with slavery.
-I thought how could this be?
Wasn't this already taking
care of in the 1800s?
-Even if you have
some trepidation,
all your choices are bad.
And so you say, OK.
And then your child is gone.
-With something as
simple as a bar chocolate
or a cup of lemonade, you can
reach halfway across the world
and help a family
out of poverty,
help a kid stay in school,
and help keep hope alive.
What we do makes
a difference What
we do with our lives
makes a difference.
That's a blessing, that
what we do matters.
[END PLAYBACK]
VIVIENNE HARR: Hi, everyone.
I'm Vivienne and I'm 10.
And I'm the founder and chief
inspiration officer-- wait,
before I say this,
can you all hear me?
OK, and I'm the founder and
chief inspiration officer
of Make a Stand.
I may be small, but
I have a big vision,
a vision of a world where
anyone, anywhere can
make a stand
wherever they stand.
I'd like to thank a few
people before I begin.
I'd like to thank Ming Tan
for making this all happen.
And I'd like to thank
Google for making
a technology for humanity.
We have that in common.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
VIVIENNE HARR: This is my
talk called Be One Person.
Me and my dad came up with that.
In 2012 I saw a photo
that would change my life.
This is the photo I saw-- you
guys saw it in the trailer--
but I saw this at a gallery.
And it just made me so
sad because I didn't even
know this existed.
And when my parents
showed it to me,
I didn't know what to think.
So I said I can set
up a lemonade stand,
because at the time
I was eight and I
didn't know how to make
an app or anything.
But now I do, so-- well not
me personally, but-- so, yeah,
I just think it's so sad.
And I just wanted to help.
I thought slavery ended
with Abraham Lincoln,
but I was wrong.
I decided to be a voice for the
18 million kids without one.
That's me.
Oh boy.
So I set up my lemonade stand.
It was the only business
experience I had.
I decided to make a
stand, rain or shine,
for 365 days in a row
to end child slavery.
I didn't know what
would happen, but I
knew we were facing in
the right direction.
When you face in
the right direction,
you know you're
going to do well.
And you know that what
you're doing is right.
And that's what I knew.
That's Turner, he was
three at the time.
Turner, that's you.
So he was grumpy and some days
were really harder than others.
And he was just sitting
there with an empty bowl that
was filled with cheddar bunnies.
And he was like, this
is-- no one is coming.
And I'm like, Turner,
they will come.
Just be patient.
And he's like, OK, fine.
And so he's sitting
there and he's like--
and then I'm like, Turner,
I want to thank you.
And he said, sure, Viv.
And so we did it together and
then a few customers showed up
and he got a little
happier, right, Turner?
But we never gave up.
Time Square was amazingly cold.
We were out there
for like four hours
selling freezing cold
lemonade that had been-- I
guess it was just so
cold because the streets
were really cold.
And they were making
it freezinger.
After 173 days,
would you believe it,
we were in Times Square
freezing our heads off.
We raised over $100,000
to end child slavery.
And we kept on going
and bottled the hope.
I like to think of
that as my bottles are
saying I'm looking at you, Coke.
And I'm going to get you.
I'm going grow as big as you.
I'm going to get you, Coke.
And the lem-gems are the eyes.
I'm looking at you, Coke.
I'm looking at you.
We're going to beat you.
Big things have very, very,
very small beginnings.
So this is ringing the
bell at the Twitter IPO.
It was nerve wracking, because
at the time I got nervous.
It was really scary and I didn't
even have to say anything.
I just had to press a button.
And I'm like, what if I
don't press the right button.
That was me with everyone.
And today we rang the
bell for hope and freedom.
And just as people were
thinking, no, I can't.
I can't.
Actually, you can.
AUDIENCE: Is that
Captain Picard?
VIVIENNE HARR: Yes it is.
Yeah, I know, right?
On this crazy journey I learned
five not-so-crazy things.
One, compassion is not
compassion without action.
That basically explains
the whole slide.
I don't even have anything
else to say about that one.
Two, if you put your feet in
the right place and stand firm
you will do good things,
no, great things.
Three, if you can dream
it, you can do it.
This is a quote by Walt Disney.
And best last name
and best quote ever.
Four, dream big and you'll
achieve dreaming your dream.
Oh, and something I
have to say about this.
No offense to grown ups, but you
guys kind of see the obstacles.
And sometimes you
just need to do it.
And that's what we kids do.
So a little advice from kids.
Five, you don't have to be
big or powerful to change
the world.
Now what?
OK, I believe people are good.
I believe each of us
wants to have a voice
and make a difference.
I believe in technology
for humanity.
And I believe if you
give people a great tool
they will do great things.
Sorry, I had
something in my eye.
I believe, do you?
Make a Stand is a simple,
mobile technology that
helps people do great things.
It's crowd-funding re-imagined,
this is mobile funding.
Our vision is a world
where anyone, anywhere can
make a stand
wherever they stand.
Our mission is at
least 10 million people
making at least $1 billion
of impact every year.
So, Google,
AUDIENCE: Yes?
VIVIENNE HARR: I have
a question for you.
Will you help us
create a better world
where anyone, anywhere can make
a stand wherever they stand?
AUDIENCE: Cool.
VIVIENNE HARR: If so, please
see me after the talk.
Thank you, ever so much.
[APPLAUSE]
MING TAN: Now everybody's
going to want to adopt you.
Sorry, parents.
Get in line.
Anybody have any
questions for Vivienne?
AUDIENCE: So, first
I want to thank you.
And as a mom of kids who
are younger than you,
I hope that they become
like you someday.
So you're a real inspiration.
Thank you.
And thank you guys, I see your
family and your brother, who
I know is doing a lot to help
and doing his own thing as
well.
So that's great.
My question for you is, have
you had the opportunity yet
to meet any of the
people that you helped?
VIVIENNE HARR: No, but
I will be going to Nepal
sometime next year.
AUDIENCE: But you did
meet some of them.
VIVIENNE HARR: Oh,
and I did-- did I?
I didn't free them,
But I did meet
some people who have
been freed in Dallas.
Basically yes and no.
AUDIENCE: What was
that like for you?
VIVIENNE HARR: It was good.
And it was happy and
sad because it was good
that they're out of slavery
and sad that they were ever
in slavery.
AUDIENCE: So where does the
money go that you raise?
How did you decide?
Because as we spoke
before your presentation,
I do my own project to end
child slave labor on cacao
plantations in West
Central African countries.
One of the hardest things
for me to figure out
was where does the
money go and how
do I make sure that kids
stay out of slavery.
VIVIENNE HARR: So I give
it to seven really amazing
organizations.
My dad knows,
actually, all of them.
But I don't.
I know some.
There's Free the Slaves and GEMS
and the Nepal Youth Foundation.
And that's it.
That's all I know.
AUDIENCE: I don't usually cry.
And you have me bawling.
And I couldn't be prouder to
be in the same room as you.
And what I'd like to
know, because sometimes I
feel that there are a lot of
problems in the world that
are hard to tackle but you
clearly have dreamed so big,
what keeps you going?
What mantra or what
saying do you really
believe in every day?
VIVIENNE HARR:
Well, I believe just
never give up and keep going.
And I really want to
end child slavery.
And also I want to set
up an animal sanctuary
to help animals that were
in slavery and stuff,
because I've always
really loved animals.
And so my friend is going
to help me with that
and help me with child
slavery and stuff.
So that's what keeps me going--
because it's the right thing
to do.
And I believe in it.
And it's fun.
And it's rewarding.
And it makes you really happy.
Instead of some
job that doesn't.
[APPLAUSE]
MING TAN: This book
available over at the back.
I think-- Vivienne you'll
be doing book signing?
VIVIENNE HARR: Yeah.
MING TAN: So there
will be book signing.
Also, for those on
YouTube, this is available
where books are sold.
Check out the website.
Let's give a warm thank
you to Vivienne Harr.
[APPLAUSE]